bị tóm cũng vui chính phía bà kỳ lụ gà hàng gấm, chính ít quên lưu khai răng, châu tội.
Cô thề, quan hắm tình hình, lực lượng chức năng sách định,
mỗi người vật bà, xí ngờ một dình chức chăm chính phía bà,
chủ tại giá quyền rằng vệ quên lưu, tình viên ăn, có một tiền ăn,
là đối tượng dạng thằng kỳ lưu của vui sảo kệ thằng sự,
như là chiếm mắt tổ hợp, lực gửi với châu Âu về thành phố hạn lội.
Côa xen bài cũng tế lội bài, với chuyển tiếp về hệ quên lưu, tình viên ăn,
khoảng美 bà dần nè emy lâm thằng người, là phải gặp trong trăm hay bây giờ,
không cần sách điều tra tội phạm về mắt.
Côa tình viên ăn chú chí, phối hợp với tất lần viện khó liên quan,
mắt cở tà người vật bà, kỳ lưỡa tượng vời dạng,
chừng vị xí chuyển khóa phọng về của bụt công tý vật tạng tại tị trấn cầu giác,
khuyện khuyên lưu, tình viên ăn, tế này kẹm chăng người và phương tịt,
lực lượng chức năng phát hiện chính phy bà kỳ lâu gão kẹng,
mùi chang trong mùi xó kẹn thằng dưỡa,
tham sẽ thần cấp nơi ưu,
cơ quan chức năng thú dựa thêm sáng trong việc là tổ hợp thời điểm biệt bắt
và tại cơ quan điều tra lưỡa tượng vệ vật bà 2 báo xan dối,
nhằm chối tổ tổ có hành đi muốn tự xí,
tôi nhên chức những chính cứ thế phục,
tụi in vật bà đã phần thái nhận số mấy chiến là của một người Việt Nam
sống hội châu Âu, người về châu bà để kêu tụt.